♪ ♪
♪
>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
WELCOME ON THIS BUSY FRIDAY
NIGHT.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS OFF FOR
ICE CREAM, SLEEP, POSSIBLY
MEDICAL CHECKS.
HIS PRESIDENCY IS IMPLODING, HIS
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE CRASHING,
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ALL
SUFFERING AND IT'S GETTING SO
BAD THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE CIRCLE
BACK JEN PSAKI.
FIRST, THE WORSENING CRISIS AT
HOME AND ABROAD.
DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE TO
DISTRACT YOU IN ANY WAY THEY
POSSIBLY CAN AND TO GENERATE
MORE PHONY OUTRAGE TO PUSH THE
FAR LEFT EXTREMIST AGENDA.
THE RAGE MOB ALONG WITH THE
DISNEY CORPORATION ARE NOW
CONTINUING TO UTILIZE ABOUT THE
FLORIDA PARENTAL RIGHTS LAW.
SO WE WILL DO WHAT THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA WON'T DO, WE WILL TELL
YOU WHAT IS IN THE LAW AND WHAT
IS NOT.
THAT INCLUDES THE PARENTAL
RIGHTS IN EDUCATION ACT.
IT IS A LAW THAT ALSO BOLSTERS
THE ABILITY OF WHAT CHILDREN CAN
KNOW, IT GIVES PARENTS A FORCE
OF ACTION WHEN THEY CROSS THAT
LINE AND THAT IS PRETTY MUCH AT
IT.
FOR WHATEVER REASON, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ENRAGED OVER
PROTECTIONS FOR PARENTS AND
CONTINUE TO FALSELY CLAIM THAT
THIS EFFECTIVELY BANS THE USE OF
THE WORD GAY.
IT DOES NOT.
AND THEY SAY THEY ARE OUTRIGHT
LYING ABOUT THE LAW, THE
EMPLOYEES RECENTLY STAGING A
WALK OUT AND NOW DISNEY SAYS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BAN BOYS
AND GIRLS AT THE PARK.
FOR EXAMPLE, CHILDREN OF ALL
AGES, AND OF COURSE LIKE
CLOCKWORK.
MORE RAMPANT HYPOCRISY INSIDE OF
CORPORATE AMERICA.
BUT WE ARE NOW LEARNING TONIGHT
THAT THE CREDIT OF THE
CAPITALIST COMPANY, STANDING
THERE WITH STREAMING OPERATIONS
INTO 10 COUNTRIES.
ALGERIA, LIBYA, MOROCCO AND MANY
OTHERS.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY CRIMINALIZE HOMOSEXUALITY
AND HAVE VERY STRICT LAWS.
ANTI-GAY LAWS.
DISNEY HAS A PROBLEM KEEPING SEX
OUT OF KINDERGARTEN BUT IS
UNBOTHERED BY ANTI-GAY
PERSECUTION ABROAD?
RON INCLUDES THE SELF GOVERNING
STATUS THAT DATES BACK TO 1967,
AND HERE IS THE GOVERNOR
EXPLAINING IT EARLY TODAY.
>> OVER MANY DECADES THEY HAVE
GOTTEN INCREDIBLE TREATMENT FROM
THE FLORIDA LEGISLATURE AND THEY
ARE TREATED ON A PEDESTAL, ONE
CORPORATION IS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I
HAVE EVER SUPPORTED AND YOU SEE
A MOVEMENT TO REEVALUATE THOSE
SPECIAL PRIVILEGES.
>> DISNEY NOW TALKS ABOUT
AUTONOMY AND RUNNING THEIR PARK
WITH LITTLE TO NO GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT.
AND THAT INCLUDES A
25,000-DOLLAR-ACRE IN FLORIDA.
AND THAT INCLUDES TOLLS ON USERS
WITH COMPLETE AUTHORITIES, THEY
ALSO HAVE EMINENT DOMAIN POWER.
THEY HAVE THE POWER TO ISSUE
BONDS AND THE POWER TO BUILD
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS.
AN DISNEY IS EXEMPT FROM STATE
AND LOCAL ZONING LAWS AND SO
MUCH MORE.
SO WHY IS DISNEY ENJOYING THESE
MASSIVE BENEFITS, AND IF THIS IS
HOW THEY ARE GOING TO ACT, WHY
SHOULD THEY KEEP THEM?
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE GOING TO
LIE ABOUT A LAW THAT DOES NOT
EXIST THE WAY THEY SAY IT IS.
WHILE REPUBLICANS AND COMMON INN
SENSE AMERICANS ARE COMMITTED TO
STANDING UP FOR STUDENTS.
WE HAVE THE FAR LEFT
CORPORATIONS, EXTREME DEMOCRATS
THAT ARE HELL-BENT ON
UNDERMINING THE DIGNITY OF
EDUCATION NO MATTER WHAT IT IS.
FAR LEFT ACTIVISM IS AT THE
CENTER OF THE MAJOR CORPORATIONS
AS THEY WORK TO TURN BUSINESS
MODELS INTO LEFT-WING PROPAGANDA
CENTERS.
EVERYDAY AMERICANS AND THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A SAY AND
MANY ARE CALLING THEM OUT FOR
THE FAR LEFT LUNACY AS ONE
MOTHER WRITES FOR THOSE THAT
LOVE THE MAGIC OF DISNEY AS
CHILDREN, IT IS DISCONCERTING TO
SEE THE OUR CHILDHOODS AND OUR
CHILDREN'S CHILDHOODS BECOMING
MORE PROGRESSIVE.
THAT INCLUDES A BRAND-NEW POLE
AT NEARLY 60% APPROVAL AND THAT
INCLUDES THE CORPORATIONS OVER
THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS